observen esta ligera capa de polvo y
partículas sueltas en estas gafas
la presión del aire facilita la visión
clara y así como la vida misma que está
llena de partículas de polvo de
interferencias que no nos facilitan el
discernimiento de un líder creíble
con estas gafas inspiró credibilidad
es probable que no
en gran parte porque el mejor diálogo ha
sido y será el de las miradas
y hablando de miradas
quiero mostrarles esos ojitos ilusión
esa soy yo de anís
la menor de cuatro hermanos mi hermana
mayor me lleva por 16 años mi padre y mi
madre trabajaban y eso hizo que mi
contexto haga que yo me esfuerce que sea
una niña aplicada una joven aplicada y
es así que entró en la universidad muy
preocupada por mi actualización por
aprender por actualizar me por ser mejor
persona y profesional
me independizó
y entró al negocio familiar
no estaba escrito que sea así pues yo
tenía hermanos mayores
entró y había cultivado algunos sellos
el sello de ser una persona aplicada
pero sentía que me faltaban algunos
otros sellos
el de la confianza recuerdo una noche de
invierno hace 16 años
solo en mi dormitorio vulnerable
me sentía derrotada
porque los resultados de la empresa en
ese año no habían sido los mejores
estábamos a rojo
y yo dudaba de que tenía el liderazgo
para sacar a la empresa de esa situación
pensaba contratar a un líder a un
gerente general que ingresé a la empresa
y rescate la misma y es así que vísperas
de mi cumpleaños me levanto hago una
reunión con mis líderes y les digo que
hacemos les planteo traer a una ex
persona externa
y me dicen no de anís creemos que en
equipo y juntos vamos a sacar esto
adelante y así fue la linda historia es
que este año terminó en azul en positivo
y aprendí lo valioso que es la confianza
y lo valioso que es la credibilidad
hasta mis 31 años admiré a donald trump
porque veían el reputación
pero algo faltaba en este personaje
y es así que aprendí que reputación no
es credibilidad
le faltaban conductas que me inspiren y
que sigan y que permitan que yo siga
este líder creíble a mis 41 años
investigó sobre credibilidad la sigo la
cultivo
y sigo a las personas que son para mí
humanamente creíbles buenas personas
el inconveniente de la credibilidad es
que la credibilidad es difícil de
observar
costes y posner
en el año 93 se plantean qué es lo que
las personas
esperan de sus líderes
y la respuesta contundente fue las
personas se esperan que en el tiempo los
líderes sean creíbles
nosotros investigamos credibilidad
tenemos una encuesta empleador líder que
llega a cerca de 12.000 trabajadores y
les hicimos la misma pregunta que
esperan de sus líderes la respuesta
contundente esperamos credibilidad y así
sale esta fórmula la fórmula de la
credibilidad que propongo este día para
todos ustedes la fórmula de la
credibilidad tiene que ver primero con
experiencia la gente necesita pericia
necesitas tener 10.000 horas de práctica
qué significan 20 horas a la semana por
cerca de 20 o 10 años
pericia entender tus dones y que tus
dones legend y se multipliquen a otras
personas
necesitas la variable y el ingrediente
de la confianza
la confianza se logra mirando a los ojos
dando golpecitos en la espalda
conectándose genuinamente con las
personas pero faltaba algún otro
ingrediente y es así que llegamos a la
inteligencia emocional que es la
habilidad y la destreza que tenemos de
reconocer nuestras emociones y reconocer
las emociones de las otras personas
yo recuerdo que estaba caminando por mi
condominio y se me acerca un amigo yo
caminaba con mi hija menor y este amigo
me dice dennis queremos postularse a que
seas parte del directorio del condominio
y le digo muy gracias porque soy mujer
de paz
y no me gusta el conflicto
y es así que mi hija me dice mami mujer
de paz
pero cuando se enoja se convierte en el
increíble hulk
esta imagen me acompaña
me acompaña donde hoy me acompaña en la
empresa me acompaña en la vida personal
y me acompaña porque yo cuido muchísimo
mis emociones
creo que eso genera una visión del líder
creíble falta algo más un elemento
importantísimo
y es que la credibilidad se cultiva en
el tiempo
se cultiva se construye no puede haber
credibilidad express
necesitamos tiempo para cultivar la
credibilidad
la credibilidad amigos míos es un regalo
y es un regalo que nos dan las personas
es la autoridad concedida es un presente
por nuestras acciones y por nuestras
conductas
hemos observado en este estudio y
analizando los liderazgos en mi país
bolivia que existen conductas que forman
parte de los líderes creíbles la primera
y contundente es que los líderes son
honestos
la credibilidad va de la mano con la
verdad
si las personas no creen en el mensajero
tampoco creerán en el mensaje y un líder
que me inspira credibilidad es barack
obama el ex presidente de los eeuu no
sólo a mí sino a muchas personas el
segundo la segunda conducta que tienen
los líderes creíbles es el ejemplo
la palabra convence pero el ejemplo
arrastra
y los líderes tenemos que tener
congruencia entre nuestras conductas
personales y las conductas profesionales
tercera conducta los líderes tienen que
ser auténticos genuinos
directos y claros
yo recuerdo antes de casarme hace ya 15
años
tuve una conversación de esas de verdad
con mi esposo porque yo tenía muchos
anhelos y sueños
nos sentamos y le explico mis anhelos
mis sueños
y que él sea consciente de que estaba
casándose con una mujer distinta
distinta
directa y clara
y decidimos casarnos estamos juntos
hasta el día de hoy
y él sabe que se casó con una mujer
directa y clara pero sobre todo una
persona que piensa dice y hace
buscando siempre la congruencia
las conductas de un líder creíble están
vinculadas a líderes que no se sobre
venden
líderes que miran por la ventana cuando
hay éxitos
pero tienen un diálogo con el espejo
cuando hay errores porque ahí está el
principal responsable que es uno mismo
los líderes tienen que tener
competencias las personas tenemos que
tener competencias pericia saber hacer
las cosas
las personas creíbles saben perder
saben ceder 18 de junio del año 2018
federico sturzenegger
en ese tiempo presidente del banco
central de argentina le envía su
renuncia irrevocable a mauricio macri y
le dice lo acompañe por 10 años
pero hoy presento mi renuncia porque mi
credibilidad está deteriorada la presión
del tipo de cambio y si él hizo que tome
la decisión más importante de toda su
vida que es la retirada
hay que ser valiente para retirarse
saber perder
saber ceder
los líderes creíbles inspiran acerca en
el futuro
comparten con otros una visión
irresistible no se puede hablar de
credibilidad sin hablar de futuro
es sencillo esto de credibilidad pero
porque tan pocas personas cultivan
credibilidad
porque la credibilidad necesita
entrenamiento diario en cada tarea en
cada momento en cada interacción humana
hay que tener control
gestionar adecuadamente nuestras
emociones
hay un estudio de pricewaterhouse que
nos dice los líderes del mundo están con
elevados de estados de ansiedad
y cuando una persona está con elevados
estados de ansiedad se siente entre la
espada y la pared y cuando una persona
se siente entre la espada y la pared no
toma buenas decisiones y nos alejamos de
las conductas creíbles
quienes han visto la serie de luis
miguel
todos nosotros la verdad que este es un
excelente ejemplo que nos permite ver
cómo una persona puede restaurar la
credibilidad
la buena noticia es que la credibilidad
se puede restaurar
soy muy agradecida con las oportunidades
que la vida me dio pero que sobre todo
las personas me han regalado
oportunidades que me permitan crecer
personalmente y profesionalmente
hace poco leí un libro de walter riso
psicólogo
la fidelidad es mucho más que amor
y el define las conductas fieles y las
conductas infieles
y al final te dice la fidelidad es una
decisión hacia la credibilidad
la credibilidad es una decisión que
tienes que incorporarla en tu proyecto
de vida
y la credibilidad es un buen negocio te
conviene las personas en un 75 por
ciento compramos a personas creíbles 18%
marcas y 7% productos
pero pongo un método que aplicó todos
los días en todo momento en toda
decisión en toda tarea y es el método
10/10/10 de suzy welch
y le propone
que cuando tengas una decisión
importante
medite reflexiones 10 minutos
porque esos 10 minutos van las van a
repercutir en los próximos 10 meses y 10
años
un líder una persona vive o muere con su
credibilidad
hace un tiempo de visita el líder de la
competencia y me dice dennis nos vamos a
presentar juntos vamos a ganar una
cuenta cliente hagamos una alianza y
cobremos sobreprecio
garantizando alta rentabilidad en los
próximos 10 años era una propuesta
indecente
qué pasó al método 10 10 10
desde luego esa decisión nos siguió
porque ponía en riesgo no sólo mi
credibilidad sino la credibilidad de la
empresa que representa
de claro
que pretendo seguir investigando la
credibilidad
he encontrado que la credibilidad no
tiene un camino lineal
está llena de avances y retrocesos como
la vida misma
la credibilidad se gana con dificultad
pero se pierde con muchísima facilidad
es fugaz
se puede fumar con nuestras decisiones y
nuestras conductas qué tan maravilloso
sería el mundo con líderes más creíbles
alejemos estas interferencias y estas
partículas de polvo que no permiten y
que nos facilitan que las personas vean
conductas creíbles en nosotros
implica té
implica a otros cultivando alta dosis de
credibilidad
mil colores en sus días
[Aplausos]